Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在切入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一个现在正在进行的令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续性收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Marianne Trent.
这些原则都对你适用。此外，还有由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）——进行一对一一小时指导的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正考虑成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的节目。
Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. It is my aim in this podcast that we illuminate different areas of psychology and where you might find yourself working or want to work one day for that matter. I also like to introduce you to people behind the professional psychology hat and so today is a really useful opportunity for us to do just that. We're going to be looking at forensic psychology as a career today, but we're also going to be looking at issues of neurodiversity, specifically ADHD and dyslexia. So I hope you find this a really useful episode. I am joined by a guest today to talk us through all of this stuff. Please do come and connect with me on the Aspiring Psychologist community free Facebook group where we can discuss this episode and more.
嗨，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。本播客的宗旨是照亮心理学的不同领域，以及你可能会发现自己工作、或者有朝一日想去工作的领域。我也喜欢向大家介绍专业心理学帽子背后的真实人物，所以今天的节目就是一个非常好的机会，让我们来做这件事。今天我们将探讨法医心理学作为一种职业，同时我们也会探讨神经多样性的问题，特别是多动症（ADHD）和阅读障碍。因此，我希望你能发现这是一期非常实用的节目。今天有一位嘉宾和我一起探讨所有这些内容。请务必加入我们“有志心理学家社区”的免费 Facebook 群组，我们可以在那里讨论这期节目以及更多内容。
And if you've got any questions or things you want help from the audience to answer, then you're welcome to post in the group as well so yeah i hope you find this a useful chat and i'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side hi just want to welcome along amy jane needham to the podcast hi amy hi thank you for joining us and you are currently a trainee forensic psychologist that's right isn't it? Yes it is yeah. Lovely and it's always lovely to introduce new branches of professional qualified psychology routes to our listeners. We've got lots that I want to talk to you about today but could we have a little bit of an overview of you you know how you got there and
如果你有任何问题，或者有什么想让听众帮忙解答的事情，也欢迎在群组里发帖。所以，是的，我希望你会觉得这是一次有用的交流，我也很期待在节目的另一端与你交流。嗨，欢迎艾米·简·尼德姆（Amy Jane Needham）来到播客。嗨，艾米。嗨，谢谢你加入我们。你目前是一名见习法医心理学家，对吗？是的，没错。太棒了。向我们的听众介绍专业合格心理学的新分支路径总是令人高兴的。今天我有很多事情想跟你聊聊，不过你能给我们做一个简单的概述吗？比如你是怎么走到这一步的，以及
um yeah why forensic would be really useful yeah so for me forensic psychology I've always been interested in sort of forensic settings um for me I just think there's so much good work that can be done there is a lot of people that win the services that have sustained trauma they've had lots of difficult life experiences and I think for me um it's a it's a field where I feel like I can do the most good and as well I just think it's really fascinating I never have two days that are the same and I think for me I kind of need that really sort of chaotic environment where two days are not the same I think if it's if things were the same day to day I think I'd become quite bored so I kind of like that it's that it is different and no two days are the same but also I work in professional I can help people as well. Brilliant and if people are listening and they're like I don't even know what a forensic psychologist is and what sort of
嗯，为什么选择法医心理学？这会非常有用。好的，对我和法医心理学来说，我一直对各种法医工作环境很感兴趣。对我来说，我认为那里可以做很多非常有意义的工作。有很多人需要这些服务，他们经受过持续的创伤，经历过许多困难的生活。我认为对我来说，这是一个让我觉得能发挥最大作用的领域。而且我也觉得它真的很迷人。我从来不会有哪两天是完全一样的，我觉得我需要那种真正有点混乱、每天都不一样的环境。如果每天的事情都一模一样，我想我会变得非常厌倦。所以我有点喜欢这种不同，每天都不重样，同时我也在从事专业工作，能够帮助别人。太棒了。如果听众在听的时候觉得，“我甚至不知道什么是法医心理学家，他们会和什么样的
clients they'd work with and in which settings could you give us a little bit of an overview in that area as well please yeah so I think um forensic psychology is a really wide field and I think people will just think oh actually you just work in prisons so that is true some forensic psychologists do work in prisons um however we tend to work with people that present any sort of challenging behaviour or forensic behaviours. But also we can work with people on the other side, so we can work with victims, we can work within the court and the criminal justice system. It is such a wide area, so it isn't just prisons and hospitals. My preference is I like working in secure hospitals or working more sort of like on the healthcare side.
客户一起工作，又在什么样的环境工作”，你能在这个领域也给我们做一个简单的概述吗？好的，我认为法医心理学是一个非常广泛的领域，人们可能只会想：“哦，实际上你只是在监狱里工作。”确实如此，有些法医心理学家确实在监狱工作。然而，我们往往会与表现出任何形式的具有挑战性行为或法医行为的人合作。但我们也可以与另一端的人合作，我们可以与受害者合作，我们可以在法庭和刑事司法系统中工作。这是一个非常广泛的领域，所以它不仅限于监狱和医院。我的偏好是喜欢在安全医院工作，或者更多地在医疗保健一侧工作。
But yeah, it's such a wide variety. If you're interested within the criminal justice system and sort of forensic behaviour, whether it be the people that commit the crimes or kind of are involved with offending or kind of the other side sort of working with victims and it's such a huge field so you kind of can work wherever and also there's forensic positions and kind of work within the community prior to the job that I'm working at now because I currently work in a secure forensic hospital but prior to that I worked in the community for the NHS so I worked on the offender personality disorder pathway so there is a huge variety of positions a different place you can work within forensic psychology. There is and there's also quite an overlap between the relevant
但是的，它的范围真的很广。如果你对刑事司法系统和法医行为感兴趣，无论是实施犯罪或卷入犯罪的人，还是另一端与受害者合作的工作，这都是一个巨大的领域，所以你基本上可以在任何地方工作。而且在法医职位之外，在社区中也有相关的工作。在我现在的工作之前——因为我目前在一家法医安全医院工作——在此之前，我在 NHS（国民健康体系）的社区工作，我参与的是“罪犯人格障碍通道”（Offender Personality Disorder Pathway）。所以在法医心理学中，有大量各种各样的职位和你可以工作的不同地方。确实如此。而且，相关经验之间也有相当多的重叠
experience for clinical counselling and forensic psychology isn't there so I know both of my assistant posts actually were forensic settings so I was a an assistant clinical psychologist within forensic population so the first was a large psychiatric hospital and the second was a youth prison but I was very keen to carve out relevant clinical stuff but within within an offending population yeah sorry one second I I'm on mouse duty um but yeah I know that that is true um and I think before there used to be such more of a difference in terms of forensic psychology or if you kind of look in like old school prison psychology it used to be very separate but I think now there is a lot less overlap between oh sorry there's a lot
比如临床心理学、咨询心理学和法医心理学，对吧？我知道我的两段助理岗位实际上都是法医环境。所以我曾在法医人群中担任临床心理学家助理，第一份是在一家大型精神病医院，第二份是在一家少管所。但我非常热衷于积累相关的临床经验，不过是在一个涉罪人群中。抱歉，等一下，我在负责操控鼠标。但是，是的，我知道这是真的。而且我认为以前法医心理学有很大不同，或者如果你看看老派的监狱心理学，它过去是非常独立的。但现在我认为两者的重叠少了很多……抱歉，有很大
more overlap between the professions and so you kind of have forensic psychologists that work in clinical settings like in hospitals and prisons in the community you have clinical psychologists that work within prisons I do think the overlap between the professions is a lot less. I think overall, we do have an understanding of what assessment is, formulation, treatment, and kind of that sort of approach to working with patients. And that doesn't really differ too much, whether it's clinical or forensic or what sort of population that you're working with and I think probably in the forensic aspect there's a little bit more training around risk we do as part of our training
多的重叠。所以你会发现法医心理学家在医院和监狱等临床环境中工作，在社区中你也会发现临床心理学家在监狱里工作。我确实认为这些职业之间的重叠并没有变少很多。我认为总的来说，我们对什么是评估、构念（formulation）、治疗以及对待患者的那种方法都有共同的理解。这并没有太大的不同，无论是临床的还是法医学的，或者你正在与之合作的是什么样的人群。而且可能在法医学方面，会有更多关于风险评估的培训。作为我们培训的一部分，我们
we um or my training anyway we had lectures specifically around violence risk assessments and sexual risk assessments and because I think stereotypically or historically that's a bit more of a forensic sort of aspect um but my supervisors have been both clinical and forensic psychologists working in hospitals so there's not really been that much of a difference. Brilliant thank you for illuminating our listeners awareness in those areas could you tell us a little bit about what your training's like and what was it really demanding is it really involved what does it what does it take from you um I find the training quite intense to be honest that there is so many different ways to kind of qualify in forensic psychology so I've chose to go down the doctoral route and so there is two universities that offer the
会……或者无论如何我的培训中，有专门围绕暴力风险评估和性风险评估的讲座。因为我认为刻板印象中或历史上，这更偏向法医方面。但我的督导既有临床心理学家，也有在医院工作的法医心理学家，所以其实没有那么大的区别。太棒了，谢谢你开阔了我们听众在这些领域的认识。你能跟我们讲讲你的培训是什么样的吗？它真的要求很高吗？它真的很繁重吗？它对你的要求是什么？说实话，我发现培训相当高强度。因为在法医心理学中，有很多不同的途径可以获得资格，所以我选择走博士路线。
doctoral route there is University of Birmingham and the university of nottingham and they kind of are based on the bps route so um you do stage one which is the msc and then you have the equivalent of stage two which is the doctorate aspect um it's kind of encapsulated all in one course and um it does have a lot more of the research element and it's kind of the extra sort of research element which is why it's the doctoral route so some of the other routes are practitioner-based routes so there is the BPS route there is the forensic practitioner route at Cardiff where you'd have to I'm not I'm gonna say I'm I don't know as much about the routes I think it's like a postgraduate sort of diploma sort of route um and regardless of what route you take when you qualify as a forensic psychologist does that mean that you're able to
有两所大学提供博士路线，分别是伯明翰大学和诺丁汉大学。它们基本上是基于英国心理学会（BPS）的路线。所以你要完成第一阶段，也就是理学硕士（Msc）；然后你拥有相当于第二阶段的资格，也就是博士学位部分。这一切都包含在了一个课程中，而且它包含更多研究元素。正是因为这些额外的研究元素，所以它才是博士路线。因此，其他一些路线是实践者路线，例如 BPS 路线，卡迪夫大学也有法医实践者路线，你必须……我得说，我对其他路线了解没那么多，我认为这就像是一个研究生文凭之类的路线。无论你走哪条路线，当你获得法医心理学家资格时，是否意味着你能够
register as a forensic psychologist with the HCPC yes so whichever route you choose to take you are you can still register with hcpc and some of the routes um are not charted so i don't i don't think the cardiff route you can apply for charged it with the bps i'm not too sure there's a little bit of variation and obviously with the doctoral route um there is the doctorate aspect as well. And I say compared to like the other routes. So I have friends that have gone down the clinical route. They've gone down the educational route. It seems to be a lot more streamlined. So you have the doctorate and that's kind of the way of qualifying, whereas forensically seems to be a little bit more sort of variation. Personally, I found the doctorate quite demanding just because I was working four days a week. Some days I was working five because I chose to use paid placements.
在 HCPC（英国健康与护理专业委员会）注册成为一名法医心理学家？是的，所以无论你选择哪条路线，你仍然可以在 HCPC 注册。并且其中一些路线不是特许的（charted）。我不认为卡迪夫路线你可以向 BPS 申请特许身份，我不太确定，这其中有一点点差异。当然，对于博士路线来说，也有博士学位的部分。而且比起其他路线，我有朋友走的是临床路线，也有走教育路线的，那些看起来要规范得多。你读个博士，那就是获得资格的途径，而法医专业似乎有更多样化的选择。就我个人而言，我发现博士学位相当吃力，只是因为我一周工作四天。有时我工作五天，因为我选择使用带薪实习。
So the doctoral route isn't funded. So I've used a doctoral loan to cover the cost of my course fees and the training is is expensive I will add that and so for me I wasn't able to do the course I wasn't able to find funded placements and so I've used assistant psychologist posts and kind of found my own sort of placements to kind of get me through the course so that had that added level of sort of a little bit of stress because I had to find posts um but the university was fine with as long as the post met the sort of criteria so they had to be with a forensic population and so I couldn't have like a post working say in an eating disorder um clinics it didn't have as much relevance in terms of forensic psychology um so yeah i had to find my place that she was quite stressful i was working a lot of
所以博士路线是没有资金资助的。我使用了博士贷款来支付我的学费，而且我想补充一点，培训费用很昂贵。对我来说，我无法参加那个课程，也找不到带薪实习，所以我使用了助理心理学家的职位，并自己找实习来度过课程。这增加了一层压力，因为我必须自己找工作。但只要工作符合标准，大学就没问题。它们必须面对法医人群，所以我不能找在进食障碍诊所之类的工作，因为那与法医心理学的关联不大。所以，是的，我不得不自己找实习，这压力挺大的。我大部分时间都在工作，周末还要做研究。
the time doing research at the weekends um so it is quite intense there isn't sort of a lot of time in terms of to write your reports to kind of do the extra sort of university work required so I I found it quite difficult and um we have a write-up year um which is so the placements are over two years so I've done four six-month placements and and within that time I've done the practitioner sort of side so I've um written placement reports have evidence competencies within the forensic psychology so they have core roles so like core one's assessment and formulation or all two's research three is like um educational there's within psychological knowledge and four is training so I've had to evidence all of that
所以它是相当高强度的。在撰写报告以及完成大学要求的额外作业方面，并没有太多的时间。所以我发现这相当困难。而且我们有一个“撰写年”（write-up year）。实习期超过两年，我完成了四次为期六个月的实习。在那期间，我完成了实践者那一侧的工作。我撰写了实习报告，证明了自己在法医心理学中的胜任能力。它们有核心角色，比如核心一是评估与构念，核心二是研究，核心三是教育——在心理学知识范围内，核心四是培训。我必须证明所有这些。
uh but then obviously I don't have the time as such to write had to evidence all of that uh but then obviously I don't have the time as such to write the reports so all of that has been done so much kind of like in spare time so I've ended up using the write-up year which I'm still in now to um still be writing up my thesis so uh yeah I found it quite full-on to be honest it sounds it it sounds it but what it also sounds like is the end is in sight Amy yes so I um we have two uh theses I'm not sure what the plural is but I have two so um I have finished my um clinical one which is kind of our practice portfolio which is our practical skills and I was vibed earlier this year and I've just got amendments to write and I'm currently in the process of finishing my research so each thesis comprised of six chapters and I'm just writing
但是很显然，我没有那种时间来撰写报告。所有这些都是在业余时间里勉强完成的。所以我最终利用了撰写年——也就是我现在所处的阶段——来继续撰写我的论文。所以，是的，说实话，我发现这非常忙碌。听起来确实如此。但听起来终点也在眼前了，对吧，艾米？是的，所以……我们有两个……呃，我不确定复数是什么，但我有两篇论文。所以我已经完成了临床那篇，也就是我们的实践作品集（practice portfolio），它关乎我们的实践技能。我今年早些时候通过了论文答辩（viva），现在只需要修改文字。我目前正在完成研究部分的收尾工作。每篇论文由六章组成，我正在撰写
like my last sort of chapter and I have got the discussion which is chapter six but in my head that that's a small chapter so it it's and it's just an overall summary so I've got one actual full chapter to write and then it's on to the discussion amazing and then you start thinking about applying for qualified roles well I'm currently in a qualified position so um some some posts will kind of be open to trainees that are either at the end of their training or um within so many months of qualifying and so my last post i was in as well was for a qualified and they were kind of just offer extra sort of support um and i guess because where my route's a little bit different i have like this sort of um like interim period so i've finished all of my core roles i've kind of evidenced all the stuff that um i need in terms
最后的一个章节，也就是第六章讨论部分。但在我脑海里，那是个小章节，它只是一个总体总结。所以我只剩下一个完整的章节要写，然后就进入讨论部分了。太棒了，然后你就可以开始考虑申请正式资格的职位了。嗯，我目前就在一个合格的职位上。所以有些岗位会向那些即将完成培训，或者在获得资格前几个月的见习生开放。我之前的岗位也是为一个合格职位设立的，他们会提供一些额外的支持。我想，因为我的路线有点不同，我有一个这样的过渡期。我已经完成了所有的核心角色，我已经证明了我在临床工作中所需要的所有东西。但因为我走的是博士路线，在我完成课程的研究方面之前，我还不能获得 HCPC 注册，也不能完全获得资格。所以我基本上完成了所有的临床工作并获得了签字认可，但在我撰写研究期间，我是“有资格但又没完全获得资格”的——如果这能说得通的话。我处于这样一个过渡期。
of my clinical work but because i'm doing the doctoral route I don't get my HCPC registration I don't fully qualify till I've finished the research side of my course as well so I've kind of finished and had all my clinical work signed off but whilst I'm kind of writing up my research I'm qualified but not qualified if that makes sense I'm in like this interim period I'm with you sort of a bit of a middle ground yeah and then does your pay go up once you are fully HCPC registered as well and so a lot of positions either so I work in a private company at the moment um and what they do is they kind of pay you in terms of your core roles so because I've obviously submitted evidence for the core roles I'm just paid at the top of like a trainee band um and then obviously once i qualified i've got
我明白，这有点像个中间地带。是的。那么，一旦你完全在 HCPC 注册后，你的薪水会上升吗？目前我在一家私营公司工作，他们做的是根据你的核心角色来付薪水。因为我显然已经提交了核心角色的证据，所以我按照见习薪酬的最高标准拿薪水。显然，一旦我获得资格、拿到注册证以及所有这些之后，我就会转到正式薪水。在 NHS 内部，我知道有些人会说“达到合格前拿第六阶（band six）”，或者他们会称之为“见习心理学家”（preceptorship psychologist）职位。这针对的是那些接近培训尾声、并希望在获得资格后直接上岗的人。我明白了，这非常有帮助。就时间框架而言，你可能知道——或者大概知道——临床心理学通常在秋天申请，然后在春天获得面试机会，接着在九月开始。法医心理学有什么可预测的模式吗？还是说一切都像是把东西抛向空中，看看会发生什么？
my registration all that sort of stuff i would move on to a qualified salary and um within the nhs i know some of them will they will say um like band six until qualified or they will call it like a preceptorship psychologist role so it's for those that are kind of near the end of training and looking sort of to be in a post for when they qualify. I'm with you that's really useful to know and in terms of time frames so you probably know or might know that site the clinical psychology you tend to apply in autumn and then hope to get interviews in spring and then it starts in September. Is there any sort of predictable pattern for forensic or is it all just like throwing up things in the air and seeing what happens? So I guess it depends what route you
我想这取决于你想走哪条路线。我认为在监狱服务部门，他们有全国性的招聘活动，会招募很多法医心理学家，并且有一个候补名单。我可以说我对这种路线不是很熟悉，但我知道他们确实有。我看到人们在 BPS 路线中发布过关于这方面的信息。至于 BPS 路线，我不太确定。我知道他们对它进行了一些改造，因为过去它就像是“绳子有多长”一样——当你完成一个核心角色的证据时，你就会进入下一个。但他们增加了一些死线和时间框架，因为过去的一个问题是人们培训花费的时间太长了。我想对我来说，这也是阻碍我选择 BPS 路线的原因之一，因为我觉得我需要那种结构化的时间表——什么时候必须完成这个，什么时候必须完成那个——来让我保持在正轨上。
want to go down. I think within the prison service they have like national sort of recruiting drives where they recruit so many forensic psychologists and there's a waiting list. I'm not, I would say, very familiar with that sort of route, but I know that they do have that. And I've seen people post about that with the BPS route. I'm not too sure. I know that they have revamped it a little bit because it used to be um like kind of like how long is a piece of sort of string it would be when you've completed evidence for one core role you'd move on to the next but they've kind of um like added like deadlines and time frames because that was one of the issues in terms it was taking people such a long time to train and I think for me that was one thing that deterred me from the BPS route was because I feel like I needed that sort of structured sort
所以对于 BPS 路线，我其实不太确定，他们的路线上有一些相关信息。如果你在网上查看我的路线，在时间安排上其实挺类似的。我想我大概是在二月份左右申请的，然后我参加了面试之类的事情，接着在那个时候获得了九月份入学的名额。九月入学，显然它遵循一个学术学期。所以对于我的路线，我觉得和临床有点类似：我做了申请，参加了面试，显然根据面试结果，我获得了九月入学的职位。我想对于其他路线来说，因为我们在工作中有其他见习生，他们走的是卡迪夫路线，他们也有面试。我想他们每年有一到两次招生，也是差不多的流程：你通过大学申请，参加面试，然后根据结果，在他们的学期开始时入学。太棒了，谢谢。我知道当我曾在住院部医院工作时，我曾与见习法医心理学家共事过。那个阶段它还不是博士路线，至少他们当时读的不是。他们觉得这非常困难，因为似乎目标总是在不断变化。他们可能正处于实习期或病房中间，然后突然间他们会重新改写他们想要的东西，或者重写期望值，他们就得从头开始。对于这些见习生来说，这听起来令人难以置信地沮丧。这种情况现在还在
of timeline of this is when you have to get this done this is when you have to get that done just to keep me on track um so for the BPS I'm not actually sure there is information sort of um on on their route I think if to look if you look online with the with my route it's a similar sort of thing in terms of um i applied i think in february sort of time um and then i kind of had the interview and that sort of stuff and i was offered a place then for september and it was September obviously like then it follows like an academic term um so I'd say for mine it is a little bit similar to the clinical I had I did my application I had an interview um obviously from the outcome of the interview then I was offered a position to start in September um I think for the other routes because um at work we have other trainees as well and they're
发生，还是变得更统一了一些？我想……因为我的路线是通过大学进行的，所有的路线都有类似的东西，但它们又完全不同。所以当我听到我们谈论的那些见习生时……他们管它们叫什么来着？SOP（胜任标准），我不确定那是什么，某种熟练程度指标。我会想：“我不知道这是什么。”我感觉所有的路线都有自己的一套流程。所以，你的路线是统一、公平且一致的，听到这个总是让人高兴。但，是的，根据人们攻读法医专业的路线不同，可能也会有其他不同的看法。我认为每个专业确实都有那么一点差异。
on the cardiff route and they had interviews i think they do one or two intakes and it's a similar sort of thing you um will apply through the university you have an interview and then depending on the outcome start obviously when their term time starts. Brilliant, thank you. I know when I was working in an inpatient hospital, I was working with trainee forensic psychologists, and it wasn't a doctoral route at that stage, I don't think, not that they were doing anyway. And they found it really difficult, because it seemed like constantly, the goalposts were changing, they might be in the middle of a placement or in the middle of the unit, and then they'd suddenly rewrite what they wanted, or what the the expectations were and they'd have to sort of start again and it just sounded incredibly frustrating for these trainees is that still
但我必须说，我的路线相当不错。我们有一本手册，上面写得很清楚。我知道我有四个实习期，我知道我必须写实习报告。所以感觉非常有结构、有条理。我想对我来说，我需要那种结构，所以这就是吸引我走向那种培训路线的原因。太棒了，谢谢。所以，是的，我们在领英上联系并聊起了你对啮齿动物的热爱，但除此之外，最近你也一直在分享你关于多动症（ADHD）评估和治疗的历程。你能跟我们讲讲你是怎么开始思考 ADHD 的，这对你来说是什么样的体验吗？
going on or has it become a bit more uniform I think I think because my route I was through the university um all the routes kind of have a same sort of thing but they're all really different so when I'm hearing that the trainees that we're talking about um what do they call them SOPs and I'm not sure what that is something something of proficiency and I'm like I don't what's this like I feel like all the routes have um their own sort of way of going through it. And so I'm not... Yours has been uniform and fair and consistent, which is always good to hear. But yeah, other opinions may be available depending on which route people are doing their forensic. I think each does have like a little bit of variation in them.
是的，嗯……对我来说，我一直有点知道自己有 ADHD。刻板印象中，当你想到患有 ADHD 的小男孩时，我非常具有破坏性。我在超市里会崩溃大哭。当你想到儿童 ADHD 的刻板印象时，我差不多就是那种孩子。我真的很有破坏性。所以我想从很小的时候起，我妈妈就知道我和我姐姐有点不同。她会觉得：“她有时确实有点挑战性。”我猜她不玩老鼠吧？其实，只有当我搬出家独立居住后，我才养了啮齿动物，但我一直都有宠物，我从小就和宠物一起长大。好吧，但你们只是非常不同类型的人。
But I do have to say like mine was quite we had a handbook which was kind of laid out I knew that I had the the four placements I knew I had to do placement reports so it was kind of it did feel very structured and laid out which I think for me I needed that structure so that's kind of what drew me towards that sort of that sort of training route brilliant thank you so um yeah we connected on linkedin and got chatting about your love of your love of rodents really um but also um more recently you've been sharing your journey about adhd assessment and treatment as well could you tell us a little bit about how you first started thinking about ADHD and what that's been like for you yeah um so for me I um I've always kind of known I had ADHD I um
是的。而且我觉得在成长过程中，说实话，就 ADHD 的评估和诊断而言，尤其是女孩和女性，比起我小时候已经有了很大的改善。我妈妈谈到她带我去评估的时候，我想我大概四岁左右——所以，呃，我现在 30 岁了，那是 26 年前。她只是说他们当时不太确定，我非常具有破坏性，所以她向她的一个朋友寻求支持。那个朋友是一位老师，但她教的是那些具有破坏性的孩子，她在学生转介机构（PRU）工作。所以我在行为干预和结构化方面得到了很多支持，让自己保持高度忙碌。因此我成长过程中，差不多就知道自己有点不同。
was stereotypically when you think of um like a a boy child with adhd i was very disruptive i was having like meltdowns in supermarkets i was when you think stereotypically of what adhd is in a child i was kind of that child i was really disruptive um so i think from kind of like really early on my mum knew i was a little bit different to my sister she was like she's a she's a little bit of a challenge at times. And she doesn't play with rats I'm guessing? Well actually it's only when I moved out from home I had rodents but I've always had pets I've always grew up with pets so. Okay but you're just very different types of people. Yeah and I think growing up um to be honest I think in terms of the sort of assessment and diagnosis of ADHD especially within girls and women has improved a lot from when I was a child
所以你当时四岁时并没有符合诊断标准，这是你后来又重新关注的事情？是在我上中学的时候。
I think my mum my mum spoke about when she took me for an assessment i think i was around four um so i mean i'm 30 now so 26 years ago um and she she just said that they um wasn't kind of sure i was really disruptive and so she kind of sought um support from her friend who was um she was a teacher but she taught children who were kind of um disruptive and she worked in a pupil referral unit and so I kind of she had a lot of support in terms of like behavioral interventions and in terms of structure keep myself really busy and so I've kind of grew up sort of knowing that I was a little bit different um so you didn't fulfill the diagnosis at four at that stage it's something you came back to it was it was when I was in secondary school um I
所以基本上每个人都知道，甚至在学校里也这样：“艾米绝对有 ADHD，她根本坐不住，她一直在说话。”我总是独自坐在课桌旁，因为不管谁坐在我旁边，我都会一直说话，我会非常具有破坏性。所以我在 13 或 14 岁左右接受过评估，结果显示他们建议我有 ADHD。然后当时出现了一个问题：我是不是想去一所不同的学校？我是不是需要去一所特殊学校？我妈妈说：“不，她挺好的。”我想这就是当时事情进展受阻的地方：如果你有这个诊断，你就必须接受不同的教育。而她则表示：“不，她挺好的。”
so it was kind of like everyone sort of knew even at school I was like Amy has definitely got ADHD like she doesn't sit still she constantly talks like I was always sat on my own on the desk because whoever was sat next to me I would just talk I'd be really disruptive um so I had kind of I had an assessment um I think I was around 13 or 14 and that kind of came they suggested that I had ADHD and then there was something around do I want to be do I want to go to a different school do I need to be sort of like go to a special school and my mom's like no she is fine like and I think that was kind of the where it's progressed a little bit it's if you have this diagnosis you have to be educated differently where she was like no she's she's fine um so I I then the school kind of provided
所以学校后来提供了一些额外的支持。因为我并没有处于那种濒临崩溃的边缘，我在学校里的成绩其实相当不错，他们甚至不知道该怎么处理我——如果老实说的话。他们会觉得：“嗯，她不需要助教，她只是有点健谈。”所以我……我甚至不知道我当时面对的是什么人。那就像是一周一个小时。我在准备普通中考（GCSE）期间经历过这个。但实际上是我的体育老师对我说：“艾米，我觉得你有阅读障碍。”他说你的书面作业很好，但你不会拼写。
some extra support if it was because I kind of wasn't on like a a cd sort of borderline I was achieving kind of really well at school they didn't know what to do with me if I'm being honest it was like well she doesn't need a teaching assistant. She is just a bit chatty. So they, I don't know what, I had this person, I don't know what I did with them. I just kind of, it was like an hour a week, but I had that whilst I think it was in through GCSEs. But then it was actually my PE teacher was like,
所以直到我上大学时，我才真正接受了很多正式评估。通过……我在预科（sixth form）多读了一年，因为我有点具有破坏性，没有去上某些课，而且有一年挂科了，所以很显然我后来重修了 A-Level 的很多东西。到了大学，我心想：“好吧，我可能确实需要接受正式评估，看看能提供什么支持。”因为我一路顺风顺水地读完教育，我要说的是，因为我
Amy, I think you've got dyslexia. And he was like like your written work is good but like you can't spell and um so it wasn't until I went to university where I actually had a lot of formal assessments so um through I had to do an extra year at sixth form because I was a little bit disruptive I didn't go to some of my classes and I failed one year so um I kind of obviously then redid a lot of things at a level and for university I was like right I probably do need to have formal assessments and have a look at what sort of support can be offered because I've just kind of coasted through education because I'm gonna say because I was
仍然取得了相对不错的成绩，我拿到了 A 和 B，直到我读预科时，那里更加自主化了，这本身并不算什么大问题——“她很有破坏性，但仍然能取得好成绩”。所以当我上大学时，他们做了一个正式评估，是通过残疾学生津贴（Disabled Students Allowance）进行的，它们真的非常好。所以我做了一个阅读障碍评估，他们审视了一切，并把所有需要的支持都落实到位，以应对我在大学期间的需求。在读大学期间，我进行了本科时期的……大学本科。是的，抱歉，是的，为了我的本科。然后我做了另一个针对 ADHD 的正式评估。这就是后来被用来——就像我说的——我现在一直在寻求额外支持的依据。但这些都是在大学期间完成的，所以我发现这相当有帮助。
still achieving like relatively good grades I got like A's and b's and like until i was at sixth form where it was a lot more kind of self-directed it wasn't too much of a problem as such like she's disruptive but can get but can still achieve and um so when i went to university they um did like a formal assessment it was through the disabled students allowance and they are really really good um so I had um a dyslexia assessment um they kind of looked at everything and put all of the things in place um in terms of what support I'd need at university and whilst I was at university I had then an undergrad uni. Yes. Sorry. Yeah. For my undergrad. And then I had another formal assessment for ADHD. And that's kind of the one which then is used, like I say, is now I've been seeking extra support. But it was from the stuff from the university and from the second sort of diagnostic opinion with what they use.
所以最初你是在做一些生活方式的改变，给自己更多的结构和常规，我猜是这样的；但最近你决定探索药物治疗的选择，对吗？是的。老实话，我在读本科时就有人提供给我药物治疗，但我认为这是一件让我一直感到非常焦虑的事情。而且我认为很多患有 ADHD 的人——尤其是像我——会将困难内化，觉得自己不够优秀。所以你会觉得……你试图掩饰问题、进行弥补，并表现得和所有人一样。
So that and again again but that was all through university so I found that quite helpful. And so initially you were sort of making lifestyle changes and giving yourself more structure and routine I'm guessing but more recently you have decided to explore medication options haven't you? Yeah and I was offered to be honest I was offered medication while I was completing my undergrad and I think it's something that I've always been really anxious about and I think as well a lot of people with ADHD me especially you kind of um internalize your difficulties and kind of feel like you're not as good so it's kind of like and you're trying to mask things and compensate and show that you're the same as everybody else.
我认为对我来说，那个时候吃药也意味着承认自己有问题，或者承认自己不够好。我知道这不是真的，但当时的感觉确实如此。所以因为我还能应付，我当时没有吃药。更多是因为在完成我的博士学位时——我全职工作，读全职课程，我和伴侣买了一栋房子，所以我显然有成人的责任——我觉得所有这些事情加在一起，让我实在无法应付了。我尽量使用行为策略，尝试规划自己的一天之类的事情，我努力保证充足的睡眠——我说“努力”，并不总是能奏效。但我觉得事情发展到了这样一个地步：
And I think for me, taking medication at that point as well was admitting that there is something wrong or admitting that I'm not as good. I know that's not true, but that's kind of how it felt at that time. So because I was able to kind of sort of manage, I didn't't take medication then and it was more so in terms of completing my doctorate and I think it was I work full-time I do a full-time course um I bought a house with my partner so I've got obviously adult responsibilities um and I think it was just everything together was just too much for me to kind of manage with um I try and obviously use behavioral strategies I try and structure my day and things like that um I try and get a good night's sleep I say try it doesn't always work but I think it got to the point where
我下班回家后精疲力竭，彻底职业倦怠了。我会去沙发上坐着，把自己卷成一个“被子卷”，并且需要被独自留置一个小时。你的功能高度正常，但代价是什么呢？而代价就是你所有的个人赤字。是的。而且我心想：“其实，这……这真的毫无帮助。”所以，就像我说的，我最初开始吃药是想着：“实际上，如果它能帮我熬过博士阶段，之后我就不需要再吃了。”但事实上，我发现它真的很有帮助。它确实在很大程度上帮助我不再感到长期的不知所措或职业倦怠。
I was like actually I'm going home from work and I'm just completely exhausted and I'm just so burnt out like I'd go and sit on the sofa and I'd be like in like a taco of quilts um and like I need to be left for an hour and I'm like you're like highly functional but at what cost and the cost was all your own personal deficit yeah and I'm like actually this this this is not helpful. So I say, I initially started the medication thinking, actually, if it helps me get through my doctorate, I don't need to take it then again after. But actually, I found it really helpful. It does kind of help in terms of not feeling chronically overwhelmed or burnt out okay that's good because I think there's probably quite a high correlation between um ADHD and psychologists I believe I definitely think I've got traits of ADHD for sure so how has it been then taking meds I remember seeing you talking about headaches and stuff initially yeah I think um one of the things that I did notice was increased temperature
好的，那挺好的。因为我想在 ADHD 和心理学家之间可能存在相当高的相关性，我相信我绝对觉得自己有 ADHD 的特质。所以，吃药之后的体验怎么样？我记得我看到你最初谈到头痛之类的事情。是的，我想……我注意到的其中一件事是体温升高。所以我通常总是相当温热……我注意到的就是体温升高。当我吃药时，比如我今天穿着 T 恤。但身体温度会升高，比如我确实头痛过，我的脑袋会觉得有点昏昏沉沉。但其中一件我常做的事是——我很不擅长记得喝水。我一整天过去都不会喝多少水。我认为这也是其中的一部分。我觉得好多了，因为我会逼自己喝水。我会备着一瓶水，心想：“好吧，我需要尽可能多地喝掉它。”
so I am always generally quite warm that I did notice was increased temperature. So I am always generally quite warm when I take my medication. Like I'm wearing a T-shirt today. But increased body temperature, like I did have headaches. I'd have quite a fuzzy head. But one of the things I would do is I'm really bad for forgetting to drink. And I'd go throughout the day and I wouldn't have drank much. And I think as well, that was part of it. I felt a lot better because I will kind of make myself drink. I'll have like a bottle of water and I'm like, right, I need to I need to drink as much as this as I can.
当我坐在办公桌前时，我会喝水。所以现在我依然注意到，主要的事情还是体温升高，但至于其他那些不适，我不知道是我在学着忍受，还是已经习惯了。除此以外，我的情况其实不算太糟。我知道有些人很难进食或者会感到恶心，我倒没有真正注意到这一点。我想也许我吃垃圾食品变少了，但我觉得那是因为以前当我无聊时，我会想：“好吧，我能干点嘛？我去吃点巧克力吧。”仅仅因为你能从吃巧克力中释放出某种化学物质，然后你得到了那种刺激……你知道的，获得更多的东西，知道得更多，是的，全都是这样。
When I'm sat down at my desk, I will drink. And so I still do notice like the main thing is like my increased body temperature but the rest of the stuff i think i i don't know if i'm just learning to tolerate it or i've just become used to it um but it hasn't other than that i haven't been too bad i know some people have um really struggled to eat or feel sick um i haven't really noticed that I think maybe I don't eat as much crap but I think that's because when I'm bored I'm like right what can I do I'll go and eat some chocolate just because it's you get that obviously then then whatever chemicals released from eating chocolate and um you're getting that stimulation you know more stuff in you know more yeah all of that and I know some of the clients I've worked with when they've started taking meds have been like oh my god have other
我知道我共事过的一些客户，当他们开始吃药时会说：“天哪，其他人一直以来都是这样的吗？而我竟然不知道？”你有过这种程度的惊叹吗，还是没有那么多？是的，我想……我的脑子真的很忙，所以我有很多想法。有时我觉得自己跟不上它们的速度：一个想法接着另一个，然后又是一个。这种情况稍微变慢了一些。所以当我写东西的时候——比如在写一个句子——我会想：“哦，下一句……哦，下一句……”而我根本跟不上。或者我正在和别人对话，突然有什么东西跳进我脑子里，或者我被分散了注意力……我正在和别人对话，突然有什么东西跳进我脑子里，或者我被什么东西分散了注意力，我就彻底开小差了。我真的很难过滤掉我的注意力该投向哪里。环境中的某样东西就会吸引我：“好吧，它在那儿，它在那儿，有人在那边说话。”我认为通过药物治疗，世界变安静了。我没有注意到那么多纷乱的想法。我觉得脑子里感觉更安静了。除了这样说，我不知道该怎么解释。
people been like this all the time and I just didn't know have you had that level of kind of ah or not so much yeah I guess it's I my head is really busy so I have lots of thoughts and sometimes I feel like I can't keep up with them so it'd be like one thought and then another and then another and that has slowed down a little bit so I'll be writing something I'll be like writing a sentence I'm like oh the next bit oh the next bit and I just can't keep up and or I'll be having a conversation with somebody and then something will pop into my head or I'll be distracted a conversation with somebody and then something will pop into my head or I'll be distracted by something and I'm fully gone like I really struggle to filter what my attention goes to it'll be something in my environment they'll be like okay it's there
但是，是的，我想我最挣扎的事情是，我会因为一个非常具体的原因打开笔记本电脑，或者打开一个新的网页，因为我需要——比如说——在领英（LinkedIn）上做点什么，或者给某人发条消息，或者在我的邮件列表软件上处理点事情。但我的主页恰好是一个随机的资讯和新闻信息流。我甚至不知道那是什么页面，但它看起来真的很有趣。上面有突发新闻头条和来自全国及本地的故事。有时10分钟过去了，我会想：“天哪，我还是没干那件事。”所以，是的，我认为关键在于要有严格的边界，识别出那些试图把你拉向不同方向的想法，然后有点像是在说：“等一下，不行，你待会儿再做。”
it's there someone's talking over there and I think with the medication it's quieter like I don't notice as many um sort of thoughts I feel like it's it feels quieter I don't know how to explain it more than that but um yeah I think that's the thing I struggle with most is that I'll come on to the laptop for a very specific reason or I'll open a new web page um because I'll need to for example do something on LinkedIn or send a message to someone or do something on my mailing list software. But my homepage is just a random feed of news and things. I don't even know what page it is. But it's really interesting. And it's got like new, you know, breaking news headlines and stories from around the country and locally. And sometimes 10 minutes will go by and I'll be like oh god I still haven't done that thing um and yeah so I think it is about being really bounded and recognizing when the thoughts
是的，绝对是这样。我会走进厨房去泡杯茶，然后在路上看到点什么——比如我在这里落了一个盘子，我会把盘子捡起来。然后我走进了厨房：“哦，我可能想吃点巧克力豆。”或者我做了别的事，接着我走回房间，却把喝的给忘了。我会想：“我是来干什么的？哦，我的茶！”然后再回去拿那杯茶。我的注意力总是会飘到各处。但我确实觉得，专注于我需要专注于的事情要容易得多，而不至于被所有事情分散注意力。这仅仅是能够安坐下来做一件事的能力。
come that want to drag you in different directions and then being a bit like hold on a minute no you can do that later yeah definitely and I I'll go into the kitchen and I'll go in for a cup of tea and then I'll see something on the way like I've left a plate here I'll pick that plate up then I've gone into the kitchen oh I might have some chocolate coins or I've done something else and then I'll come back and I'll have forgot my drink and I'm like what did I go in for oh my tea go back and get the cup of tea and it's just my attention can go everywhere but I do feel like it is a lot easier to kind of focus on what I what I need to focus on rather than being so distracted by everything and I think just the ability to be able to sit and do something.
这些事情会把你拉向不同的方向，然后就像是等一下，不，那个可以以后再做，是的，确实如此。我会去厨房倒杯茶，然后在路上看到一些东西，比如我在这里留了一个盘子，我会把那个盘子捡起来，然后我进了厨房，哦，我可能会吃一些巧克力金币或者做了别的事情，然后我回来时却忘了我的饮料，我在想我到底是去干什么的，哦，我的茶，回去拿那杯茶，我的注意力可能会飘到任何地方，但我确实觉得专注于我需要专注的事情要容易得多，而不是被所有的事情分散精力，而且我认为这就是能够坐下来做事情的能力。
So I use an app called Forest because I really struggle to sit and do my work. My phone is my enemy. I'll be like, oh, I can go on LinkedIn. Oh, I can go on WhatsApp. Oh, there's TikTok. I'll just watch two videos like an hour later. I'm like, well, that was helpful. So this app disables everything. And I grow like well that was helpful um so this app disables everything and I grow like a little tree but if I go on to the apps it will kill my tree and I'll have a dead like a wilting tree in my
所以我用了一款叫 Forest 的应用，因为我真的很难静下心来工作。我的手机简直是我的敌人。我会想，哦，我可以刷领英（LinkedIn）。哦，我可以看 WhatsApp。哦，有抖音。我只看两个视频就好，结果一个小时后，我心想，这可真有帮助。所以这款应用会禁用所有东西。然后我会种出一棵小树——但如果我去用别的应用，它就会杀死我的树，我的树就会死掉，或者像枯萎的一样……
forest really don't want a wilting tree in my forest so it will stop me from kind of going off topic because I can't um but I will notice when I'm picking my phone up and it'll say um stop fubbing like get back to what you're doing your phone is distracting you um but I'd set it for 15 minutes and then I'd be still picking my phone up but I can set it for I could probably set it for about half an hour to 45 minutes now and I've had it where my time has gone off and I'm still kind of doing my work and going from being able to concentrate probably 15 minutes to like an hour so it has it has made like a positive difference um yeah and how does that crop up for you when you're in client sessions or when you're doing clinical work with people um I think it's it's definitely
森林里我真的很不希望我的森林里有一棵枯萎的树，所以这会阻止我开小差，因为我没法这么做。不过我会注意到当我拿起手机时，它会提示我“别老看手机了，快回到手头的事上来，你的手机在分散你的注意力”。不过我之前会设置15分钟，然后还是会不断去拿手机，但现在我可以设置成半小时到45分钟左右了。而且有过这种经历：时间到了，我还在继续工作，注意力集中的时间从大概15分钟延长到大约一个小时，所以这确实带来了积极的改变。是的，这在你的客户咨询中，或者当你和别人做临床工作时，是如何体现出来的呢？嗯，我觉得这绝对是……
because it's work that I'm like kind of prepping and kind of stuff like that I'm I'm okay but I struggle more in sort of like long meetings so if we have like um ward round and it's like three hours and we've got we're seeing six people and I'm like I'm just going to go to the toilet a minute or when there's a gap between when we've seen people or sometimes we'll have like a meeting before ward round I'm like it's gonna be a long day and I'd come back and I did for me on my ward ward round was at the end of the day so I'd come back up and I'd be like it's five o'clock I've got an hour and I literally I wouldn't be doing anything that functional it'd be do I need to type something up do I need to tidy my desk do I need to sort some files because
因为这是那种我在准备中的工作，或者类似的事情，所以我还可以。但我更难应付的是那种比较长的会议，比如我们有病房查房，持续三个小时，我们要看六个人，而我会想“我得去趟厕所”，或者在我们看完人之间的间隙，有时我们在查房前会开个会，我会想，这将会是漫长的一天。等我回来时——对我来说，查房是在一天结束的时候，所以我回到楼上，心想现在5点钟了，我还有一个小时，而我字面意义上什么实际的事情都没干，我是在想：我需要打字吗？我需要整理桌子吗？我需要整理文件吗？因为……
I'd literally be fried um and so I found the meeting side a lot harder. But again, that's been a lot easier with the medication. I still kind of get up and walk around and like, I'm just going to go to the toilet because it just breaks it up a little bit more. But I think that's where it kind of affects me, obviously, is long meetings. Oh, I hated meetings. Honestly, the way to kill my soul was to invite me to a meeting. And often I used to find that meetings could have just been an email as well.
我简直快累焦了。所以我觉得会议这部分要难得多。不过话说回来，吃药之后这容易多了。我还是会站起来走动走动，比如，我只是去趟厕所，因为这样能稍微调节一下节奏。但我觉得这正是在长会议中对我有影响的地方。哦，我讨厌开会。老实说，消磨我灵魂的最好方法就是邀请我去开会。而且我经常发现，很多会议其实发个邮件就行了。
Like this didn't this didn't need to happen. And obviously when you're is slightly different in forensic services and when you're trying to make team decisions as well, because you need to have that MDT input. It is really tricky to have that sustained attention and to hold all those different ideas and different opinions in mind. And they are long, you know, and that's why when I was in psychiatric hospital they used to get nice biscuits for us to make that attention more likely but I definitely did have a slightly you know enlarged waistline when I was working in services with nice biscuits. I do have to say uh the psychiatrist on our ward she always brings lovely biscuits
就像这种事根本没必要发生。显然，当你身处法医心理服务机构时情况会稍有不同，当你试图做出团队决策时也是如此，因为你需要多学科团队（MDT）的意见。要保持持续的注意力，并在脑海中容纳所有这些不同的想法和不同的观点，真的很棘手。而且会议真的很长，你知道的，这就是为什么当我在精神病院时，他们会准备好吃的饼干，好让我们更有可能集中注意力。不过我在服务机构工作时，吃着美味的饼干，腰围确实稍微变粗了。我必须得说，我们病房的精神科医生总是带可口的饼干……
and there's always nice teas and coffees um and I'm like yeah this is a good ward round yeah I hear you thank you so much for sharing your insight and information so freely and warmly with us is there anything I haven't asked you, Amy, that you think would be useful for the audience to know, or that you wish I had asked you? I guess for me, one of the things which I found helpful is being a lot more open about having ADHD and neurodiversity. And I guess for me, it's one of the things that I've always kind of been a lot more kind of resistant about sharing due to kind of, I guess it's the fears of the negative connotations of ADHD. And especially working in forensic settings, I'd be like, like we work with patients who have ADHD.
而且总有好喝的茶和咖啡。我会想：太棒了，这真是一次好的查房。是的，我懂你的意思。非常感谢你如此大方、热情地与我们分享你的见解和信息。艾米，有没有什么问题是我没问过你，但你觉得对听众来说会很有用，或者你希望我问你的？我想对我来说，觉得有帮助的一件事是，对于自己患有 ADHD（注意缺陷多动障碍）和神经多样性这件事，表现得更加开放。我想对我来说，这曾经是我一直比较排斥分享的事情之一，因为——我猜是因为害怕 ADHD 带来的负面含义。特别是当我在法医心理机构工作时，我会想：我们服务的患者就有 ADHD。
Do they think that I'm going to do something? People who employ me think I'm going to do something impulsive. Do you think it's going to affect my ability to do my job and I think this is something I was really kind of concerned about and was kind of a barrier to me kind of being a lot more open but actually I've found kind of the opposite so um um I've shared that I have ADHD and dyslexia with my team and um my supervisor is incredibly supportive and actually it's been really beneficial because there's that kind of like shared then understanding of um say for example if i go to a session and or i'm doing sort of group work with it and i'm working with somebody else and just kind of that extra have we got everything because i might forget it and i think sometimes symptoms of ADHD can be perceived negatively and I think if people
他们会觉得我要做出什么举动吗？雇佣我的人会认为我会做一些冲动的事吗？你觉得这会影响我做工作的能力吗？我觉得这是我真的很担心的事情，也是阻碍我更加开放的障碍。但实际上，我发现情况恰恰相反。所以……我跟我的团队分享了我患有 ADHD 和读写困难的事，我的主管给予了极大的支持。实际上这真的很有益，因为这样就有了对彼此的共同理解。比如，如果我去参加一个咨询，或者和别人一起做团体工作，而我和另一个人合作时，多了一份额外的关照：“我们东西都带齐了吗？”因为我可能会忘。而且我觉得有时候 ADHD 的症状会被消极地看待，我觉得如果人们……
aren't aware it could be perceived as I'm just not prepared or I'm not I don't care about doing work with other people because I've forgot the materials I've not prepped and which actually isn't the case like sometimes I've just genuinely forgot or my organization isn't as good um but I found it been really helpful sort of being open and sharing that with my team and they've actually said well actually no it's really beneficial because you have that added insight in terms of um how ADHD affects you is the only way that I can alter sessions and make them a bit more sort of user-friendly for for patients who can't focus for an hour so yeah I found that it has been positive being a lot more open with my team um I do get that sometimes that there is also the flip side you may not have such
不了解情况，可能会觉得我只是没有准备好，或者我不在乎和别人一起工作，因为我忘了材料，没有做准备——而事实并非如此，有时候我真的只是忘了，或者我的组织能力没那么好。但我发现对团队保持开放并分享这些真的很有帮助。他们甚至说：“其实这真的很有益，因为你有了额外的洞察力，知道 ADHD 是如何影响你的。”这也是我调整咨询方式、让它们对无法集中专注一小时的患者更友好的一种方法。所以，是的，我发现对团队更加开放带来了积极的影响。我确实明白，有时候硬币的另一面是，你可能遇不到那么……
a supportive work environment but um as a whole I've found more people are supportive than not supportive good I'm really pleased to hear that. And I guess this is some of the considerations for the pathologizing nature of certain kind of conditions, really, because it doesn't make you any different. It's a framework for understanding the things that you struggle with and the things that are more effortless for you. And actually, as we increase people's knowledge and understanding about a variety of presentations, including ADHD,
支持你的工作环境。但总的来说，我发现支持我的人比不 apoio 的人多。很好，听到这个我真的很高兴。我想这也是考虑到某些病症的病理化性质，因为这并没有让你变得不同。它只是一个框架，用来理解那些让你感到挣扎的事情，以及那些对你来说毫不费力的事情。实际上，随着我们增加人们对各种表现形式的了解和理解，包括 ADHD，……
people would understand that this is an area, you know, in forensic psychology that you're highly interested in. And so you're going to have more ability to be able to, you know, to do those tasks and see things through from beginning to end. Whereas if there's something you really had no interest in then that's going to be really much more of a struggle to to make yourself engage with and make yourself follow through on yeah I think that is one of the things that I struggle with the most if it's something which I don't like or it is boring it is like pulling teeth but I guess if it's something that you're interested in,
人们就会明白，这是你在法医心理学中非常感兴趣的一个领域。所以你会有更多能力去做这些任务，并把事情从头到尾推进到底。而如果是你一点兴趣都没有的事情，那么强迫自己去投入、强迫自己坚持到底就会是一场艰难的挣扎。是的，我觉得这正是我最挣扎的事情之一。如果是我不喜欢或者很无聊的事情，就像拔牙一样痛苦。但我想如果这是你感兴趣的事情，……
I don't know, like I can sit and go through stuff. I can like plan something for hours. If it's something that I'm interested in, like you've got my full attention. Brilliant, ditto. And if someone's listening to this and thinking oh I wonder if I might you know this rings a bell you know this is resonating with me there are adult neurodiversity services in the UK isn't there is that the best thing to do or
我不知道，就像我可以坐着把东西梳理完。我可以花几个小时做计划。如果是我感兴趣的事情，你知道的，你就能得到我全部的注意力。太棒了，同感。如果有人听到这里，心想：哦，我在想我是不是也这样，这听起来很耳熟，这引起了我的共鸣——英国有成人的神经多样性服务，对吧？那是最好的选择吗，还是说……
do people go to their GP what would be your advice I I think one of the difficulties with the NHS services is they do have incredibly long wait times and I do know that is is a difficulty for people who obviously I wanted to seek support so I already had a diagnosis so when I went through the service and they was just able to look at my previous notes and all the other things um and i still had to wait around five or six months um and i think for a diagnosis i think the waiting times are it is so i'm nottinghamshire and i think it's around 18 months for adhd and over two years for autism um i would definitely recommend kind of going to seek the support if if you need to because i do think it's beneficial um there is always the option to go private but the difficulty i found is that some nhs services will not accept private diagnoses and so i'm saying mine was through the nhs
人们应该去找全科医生（GP），你的建议是什么？我认为英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）服务的一个困难在于，它们的等待时间长得惊人，我也知道这对于那些显然想寻求支持的人来说是个难题。所以我当时已经确诊了，所以当我通过这项服务时，他们只需要查看我以前的病历和所有其他资料。尽管如此，我还是等了大约五到六个月。而且我认为对于确诊来说，等待时间……我在诺丁汉郡，我觉得 ADHD 的等待时间大约是 18 个月，自闭症则超过两年。如果需要的话，我绝对建议去寻求支持，因为我真的认为这很有益。私立医疗始终是一个备选项，但我发现的困难在于，一些 NHS 服务不接受私立确诊。所以我当时是通过 NHS……
anyway so they was obviously they was quite happy to accept my diagnosis um but they said as well if i had if i had gone privately and i had a private diagnosis they would have had to reassess through the nhs so i don't know if that's just my service but i think that's something to be aware about because okay the assessments are expensive the medication's expensive it's not through the nhs so i definitely would recommend going and seeking that extra support and if you can persevere i I would go through the NHS just because I'd hate for somebody to spend thousands and then still have to go back through the NHS. One bit of advice I would recommend is if you are within education is to go through either disabled students allowance or to go through your university um to the gp because i found that a lot lot quicker that's how i got my diagnosis thank you um recently um i'm aware of some clients
无论如何，他们显然很乐意接受我的确诊。但他们也说过，如果我是通过私立渠道确诊的，他们就必须通过 NHS 重新进行评估。所以我不知道这是否只是我们当地服务机构的情况，但我觉得这是需要注意的一点。因为评估很贵，药也很贵，如果不是通过 NHS 的话。所以我绝对会建议去寻求额外的支持，如果你能坚持的话，我还是会走 NHS 渠道，因为我真不希望有人花了几千英镑，然后还得重新通过 NHS 来一遍。我给出的一个建议是，如果你还在上学，可以通过残疾学生津贴（DSA），或者通过你的大学去找全科医生，因为我发现这样快得多，我就是这样拿到诊断的。
that had gone um for assessment for adhd via a psychiatrist actually. And once they was diagnosed and had started and tolerated medication, the NHS did then agree to do, you know, to issue their prescriptions to take over their care. So it might well be a difference depending, you know, on where you live. But yeah, it's, I think if you can afford to go private or someone to help fund that private it's it's definitely worth exploring um yeah because it can be transformational when we're looking especially aspiring psychologists you know 18 months is a long time to wait isn't it when you're trying to progress your career and get on with your life yeah definitely and um from one of the private services that i
谢谢你。最近我听说有些客户是通过精神科医生去进行 ADHD 评估的。一旦他们确诊并开始且耐受了药物治疗，NHS 随后确实同意接手，你知道的，开处方并接管他们的护理。所以情况可能会有所不同，这取决于你住在哪里。但如果你负担得起私立医疗，或者有人能资助私立医疗，这绝对值得探索。因为这可能是变革性的，尤其是对于立志成为心理学家的人来说，等待 18 个月是很长的时间，不是吗？当你正试图推动自己的职业发展并继续生活时。是的，绝对是。而且从我了解的其中一家私立机构来看，……
looked at they they had that sort of option in terms of when you was on a stable sort of dose and your medication was stable they would transfer you back to your gp um so i think it is solely dependent on kind of your location what your uh gp or nhs service locally will provide because if I I found it really hard waiting six months and so I can't imagine how difficult it would be to wait the two years and then you've got it is such a long time so yeah yeah I do I do sympathize with people going through that process absolutely thank you so much for your time today, Amy. I am so looking forward to seeing when you become Dr. Amy Jane Needham on LinkedIn. I'm sure you are as well.
他们有这样一种选择：当你达到稳定的剂量、药物状况稳定时，他们会把你转回给全科医生。所以我觉得这完全取决于你所在的地点、你的全科医生或当地的 NHS 服务机构能提供什么。因为我当时觉得等六个月已经很难了，所以我无法想象等两年会有多痛苦，那时间真的太长了。所以，是的，我真的很同情经历这个过程的人。非常感谢你今天抽出时间，艾米。我非常期待在领英上看到你成为艾米·简·尼德姆博士（Dr. Amy Jane Needham）的那一天。我相信你也很期待。
Thank you. Wow. Wasn't that lovely? Amy wanted me to let you know that she had a poorly mouse with her because she's a rodent mama. And so she was having to keep a an eye and half a brain on this mouse um who keeps um keeps hurting themselves um accidentally um so yes um she really enjoyed the chat with us but she was slightly mouse aware at times as well um so if you've got any ideas or thoughts or insights into this episode or it's evoked anything for you, then come and chat with us in the Aspiring Psychologist community group and let us know how it felt for you, how it landed for you. And if you enjoyed the episode, please do take a moment to rate and review it on Apple Podcasts.
谢谢。哇，那不是很美好吗？艾米想让我告诉大家，她身边带着一只生病的小老鼠，因为她是个“啮齿动物妈妈”。所以她必须分出一半注意力和心思在这只老鼠身上——它总是莫名其妙地弄伤自己。所以是的，她真的很享受和我们的聊天，但有时也难免分心惦记着老鼠。所以，如果你对这一集有什么想法、感悟或见解，或者它触动了你，欢迎来到“有志心理学家”（Aspiring Psychologist）社群小组与我们交流，让我们知道你的感受。如果你喜欢这一集，请花一点时间在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上为它评分和评论。
And if you're watching on YouTube, which is a possibility, it's Dr. Marianne Trent, then please, whilst you're there, like the video, subscribe to the channel, and why not drop a comment in there to let me know how you found it. I will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which is available at 6am every Monday morning. Thank you so much for being part of my world and I'll catch up with you very soon. Take care. Thank you. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective The Aspiring Psychologist Collective If you're looking to become a psychologist
如果你正在 YouTube 上观看（这也是可能的，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士/Dr. Marianne Trent），那么请顺便点个赞，订阅频道，并留个言告诉我你的观感。我期待在我们的下一期“有志心理学家”播客中与你相见，该播客每周一早上6点更新。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我们很快再聊。保重。谢谢。有志心理学家集体。如果你想成为一名心理学家……
Then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
那就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身旁，你就在通往获得资格的路上。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的“有志心理学家”播客。我叫加娜（Jana），我是一名心理健康见习从业人员。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我觉得里面所有的不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。令我惊叹的是，通往这一职业的道路竟然有这么多，并没有成为心理学家的唯一完美方式。这给了我满满的信心，让我觉得我并没有做错，也减少了我的自我施压。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，就再也舍不得放下了。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。